why did we expand into things like
Electronics tools and kitchen since
those businesses are not today
profitable and the answer is that
increases our addressable Market size so
we can ultimately build a much larger
Company by entering into those new
product categories and and second while
it's true that those new categories
which are only three years old and by
the way Electronics Tools in kitchen is
now a 600 million dollar business at
amazon.com which makes it probably in
the top four or five e-commerce
companies anywhere in the world so that
business is growing and growing very
rapidly and has it one of the big
advantages it has has a huge audience of
early adopters which is why companies
like Segway choose us as the exclusive
launch platform for products like that
because really early adopters are the
kind of people who buy stuff like this
but that business ultimately will be
Electronics in particular in my opinion
will be our largest most profitable
business one day when you start a new
business there are certain fixed costs
that come along with starting that
business and then the business has to
reach enough scale so that the profit
from the business the variable profit
can cover those fixed costs there's no
sidestepping that and it's just a simple
investment issue most entrepreneurs
diversify too quickly most entrepreneurs
are focused for whatever reason on
having 14 different income streams
instead of doing what actually matters
which is getting one down that's paying
you so many people who are bragging
about their 14 income streams or 15 or
20 or 7 none of them are making money
it's great that you have an income
stream that pays you 100 bucks a year
but that's not actually getting you
where you want to go and the challenge
is you end up spending so much time
trying to set up these different
Diversified income streams that you're
not ever putting enough energy into any
of them to get traction and get results
it's unfair to look at
what you can do now and compare yourself
to a Jeff Bezos from Amazon or even
compare yourself to to what I can do
with a team of 37 people compared to
what you can do now
the way that all of your Heroes built
their businesses and their wealth is by
focusing on one thing and making it
amazing and being world-class at it and
great at it and then diversifying so
this really depends on the stage and
cycle that you're at but most of the
people who are watching you're in the
early stage you're trying to figure out
how to make this business go you want to
turn it into a full-time thing and
eventually hire team and build and grow
and scale if that's where you're at now
if you're in the the build mode and this
isn't a full-time business for you yet
then
diversification is not the strategy
focus is the strategy pick the one thing
you can be great at given insane value I
get amazing at it
and then go make some money doing it to
then build your big Vision which is
going to be a lot more Diversified
when I look at my business people ask me
Movie Makers well what should I do
should I should I have my YouTube
channel and should I do be doing
Instagram and doing coaching and books
and courses and
inside Movie Makers we're training
thought leaders right how do you build a
business around your ideas what you've
been through your purpose comes to your
pain you want to serve how do we turn a
business out of that and for a lot of
them they're just doing way too many
things and as a result nothing gets done
well I want to write a book and I want
to be a speaker I want to have my
YouTube channel I want to have courses
and a membership program and of course
do coaching and I then as a result
you're so busy trying to set up all
these different things that nothing ends
up happening it's insanely slow across
the whole board because you feel like
you have to have diversification in case
one of the streams goes away but one of
the straight none of the streams are
making any money
so who cares if they go away right like
that's what that's the focus that you
need to have at the beginning is let's
set up a a sizable consistent stream of
Revenue coming in and then you can worry
about diversifying honestly there's too
much time being spent on the wrong
things and it's just a sequence right
it's like not that you give up on those
things there's just a timing to it if
you actually want to accomplish them the
better way to accomplish them is with
the team right if you have 10 things
that you want to do the way to actually
accomplish them is to have Team help you
go and accomplish them
great how do I get team by focusing on
one thing and making it give you money
so that then you can afford the higher
team
so if you look at your list of 10
different things that you can do you
should focus on okay out of these 10
things what is the thing that I love
that can bring me some immediate money
that then I can pay myself that's good
that I can provide for my family that's
good and then maybe hire somebody
part-time to eventually full-time that
then they can ease some of my burden and
then I can focus on
building this one pipeline stronger or
building a second pipeline right that
should be the focus and so it's
frustrating because there's you've got
so much potential and so much heart and
so much talent so many skills and just
such a desire to serve that
doesn't happen because there's too much
diversification going on
so what's the order so as I'm working
through with movement makers okay you
need to pick between all these things
what's going to make you money
because making money is important
you know I think some people feel like
money is everything it's not and some
people feel money is the root of all
evil it's not money's a tool and it and
it needs to be important if you're going
to have a business in my world of
thought leadership coaching is a great
way to do it because you people say well
you're just trading time for money yes
but you're you're making money where if
you're writing a book you're not making
money right in the book if you're
speaking you're not making money as a
speaker early on in your career right
now if you start building up enough
attention and enough momentum and enough
you know history and traction experience
yes you get paid to do it but the
problem is most people will quit right
like if it's going to take you seven
years or five years or three years to
get a paid speaking gig something that's
actually
you know reasonable not 100 bucks to
speak somewhere most people will quit on
that Journey because they're not seeing
momentum and traction fast enough
because you're trying to diversify so
much and do everything and then nothing
ends up happening and you end up
quitting
and going back and getting the job
and that's really frustrating
yeah because because it can work it's
just getting about it's just about
getting the sequence right so think
about your big vision
what do you want to accomplish what's
the world you want to create we love
doing this as entrepreneurs right like I
want to build a world where X happens
right for me I want to build the world
where people believe in themselves I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem what does that look like awesome
now inside of that
what's the next step that you can take
that can start getting you paid
if you're at the early stages that's
what you have to figure out what's a
problem you can solve that is not the
you're not going to be doing this one
thing forever right because that sounds
boring and like a death sentence for
entrepreneurs we're not going to just do
this one thing forever but it's our
first step that we have to not
not see 10 projects through it's a 50
but get one really good project through
a hundred percent
that's what matters most of your
projects you start and stop and start
and stop you're doing 10 different
things and you're seeing them through 30
done 50 done 70 done it's never done 100
percent
and so you never get results pick the
one thing that can actually start paying
you push it through 100 get it done
start getting paid and now you're now
we're on track
now you're ahead of 95 of business
owners who get started because you're
actually making money and support
yourself it's a big big big big
difference diversification then becomes
fun in the future right
but if if I'm going back for me
what am I doing now
if I was just getting started now or if
I if everything went away you know I
know what I know but everything goes
away I get asked this question I'm doing
podcasts like if you know what you know
now
but everything went away and you had to
start over from scratch what would you
do I would not be doing most of the
things that I'm doing because I don't
have team
I could not be making as many videos as
they do because I don't have team I
would not be doing
movement makers I would not be doing my
gaming channel I would not be doing so
many of the things that I'm doing right
now that are fun that bring me joy that
are part of my big mission but they're
not immediately monetizable at the
beginning
so I wouldn't be doing those things yet
but I'd have
goals and Ambitions to go off and do
them
and so I think a lot of entrepreneurs
get stuck on that for whatever reason
we've been trained that you need to have
so many streams of income you don't and
you shouldn't at the beginning you don't
diversify at the beginning it's a
terrible move
and then two
inside of your your big idea what's the
one that will start getting you paid if
you could focus on that this year just
imagine on where that takes you right in
the next 12 months you got to the point
where you're if you're just starting out
you get to the point where you're
supporting yourself you don't have to
have a job anymore you're paying your
bills and your family's bills maybe
hiring somebody part-time full-time
what a different world that looks like
for you versus doing 10 different
projects on the side part-time never
completing any of them if you're already
full-time in your business
even just doubling down on what's
working
imagine how much bigger you could be if
it's just you or you have one person not
imagine if you have 10 people working
with you on this thing
often the path to get there is to not
add another thing in but to double down
on what's already working I make it
bigger I make it better
and improve it
diversification is fun don't get me
wrong it's amazing diversification is a
great risk management strategy
ultimately
but
it's usually a terrible idea especially
when you're first getting started in
your business the people who you look up
to look at their early Journey see how
they won see how they got started they
focused they were hyper focused they got
amazed at something they got paid to do
it and then the diversification came as
they had even more success and more
energy and most importantly more team to
help them do it also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start build in the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
I always tell people sometimes I get you
know we'll have a good
um quarterly conference call or
something and and Wall Street will like
our quarterly results and I'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and I
say thank you but what I'm really
thinking is that quarter was baked three
years ago I right now I'm working on a
quarter that's going to reveal itself in
2021 sometime and that's what you need
to be doing you need to be out sort of
you know two or three years in advance
and if you are and then why do I need to
make a hundred decisions today if I make
like three good decisions a day that's
enough and they should just be as high
quality as I can make them take part of
your choices out your gifts this is
something that um I would I think is
super important for young people to
understand and for parents to preach to
young people it's really easy for a
talented young person to take pride in
their gifts they can say you know I'm
really athletic or I'm really smart or
I'm really good at math and that's fine
you should celebrate your gifts you
should be happy but you can't be proud
of them because they're gifts after all
they were given to you but you can be
proud of is your choices how did you
decide to use your gifts did you study
hard did you work hard did you practice
the people who really Excel combine Gift
gifts and hard work and the hard work
part is a choice you get to decide that
and that is something when you're
looking back on your life you'll be very
proud of when you buy over the Internet
Amazon do you ever get the wrong orders
anything ever wrong what do you do if
you call up and complain or you don't
have any problems no I I I I'm I'm a
customer of Amazon hopefully like all of
you in this is there one person
full-time services in this room who's
not an Amazon Customer see me right
afterwards and I'll um I'll walk you
through it it's um I I yeah I get I have
problems sometimes
um and I and I treat them like the same
way I treat a problem that I would get
from customer my email address is famous
and I keep it and I read it it's Jeff
amazon.com I don't see every email that
I get anymore because I get too many but
I see a lot of them and I use my
curiosity
to pick out certain emails I'll get one
from a customer and there's a defect you
know we've done something wrong that's
the usually people are writing us not
always but usually the writings because
we've screwed up their orders somehow
and I am so I look at this and for some
reason it's something seems a little odd
about that one and so I'll ask the team
to do a case study and and find real
root cause or causes it's usually causes
really root causes and then real root
fixes so that when you fix it you're not
fixing it for that one customer you're
fixing it for every customer and that
process is a gigantic part of what we do
so I would treat my if I have a failed
order or some bad customer experience I
would treat it just like that Amazon has
14 leadership principles and this is the
one that often catches people a little
by surprise because one of our
leadership principles is the good
leaders will write a lot and
um
it sounds kind of like well great but is
there some way that I can practice being
right a lot and you're not going to read
all the time but I do think you with
practice you can be right more often and
I've observed people who are right a lot
and I notice a few things about them the
first is that people who are right a lot
they listen a lot and people who are
right a lot change their mind a lot and
uh people who are right a lot they seek
to disconfirm their most profoundly held
convictions which is very unnatural for
humans so humans mostly as we go about
life we're very selective in the
evidence that we let seep into us and we
like to observe the evidence that
confirms our pre-existing beliefs and
people who are right a lot work very
hard to do that unnatural thing of
trying to disconfirm their beliefs when
I started Amazon it was 25 years ago I
started Amazon in 1994. when I went to
seek investors the first question I had
to answer is what is the internet none
of my investors had ever heard of the
internet
and the
the the the idea that I had in mind was
to build a bookstore I realized that we
could build a store which would have
every book ever printed in any language
in print or out of print and we could do
that online it would be impossible in a
physical store and that was the founding
idea of Amazon and but did I expect what
would happen today no you know we
started uh I've been at Amazon when it
was one person me when it was 10 people
when it was a hundred people when it was
a thousand people and today when it's
you know more than 700 000 people and
approaching 70 000 people just here in
India so no I did not predict that and
actually I think if anybody had
predicted that they would have needed to
be immediately institutionalized in a
mental facility because it's not a
normal thing to have happen my dream
when I started Amazon was that one day
we might be able to afford a forklift so
it's been a very a fun Journey for me
and by the way I still tap dance into
work I'm having so much fun one of the
reasons we have been able to extend into
new business areas and first new product
categories going way back we just sold
books and then we started some music and
DVDs and electronics and toys and so on
and then we've extended in into
electronic reading with Kindle the
reason customers have been receptive in
large part to our new initiatives is
because we have worked hard to earn
trust with them earning trust with
customers
is is a valuable business asset and if
you mistreat their data they will know
they will figure it out customers are
very smart you should never
underestimate customers my grandparents
would take me every summer even starting
at age four every summer kind of to give
her a break really for the whole summer
so I'd be with my grandparents and on
their Ranch in Cotulla Texas which is
halfway between San Antonio and Laredo
we lived in Houston and uh so we would
make the five hour drive out to katula
they dropped me off it's been a couple
days there then they go back to Houston
I'd spend the summer and I went every
day to the ranch with my grandfather to
help now a four-year-old boy on a ranch
in South Texas it's not a lot of help
but I didn't know that I thought I was
helping and um and then as I by the time
I was 16 I actually was helping so I
have you know I I can
I can suture up a prolapsed cow I can
fix windmills
um my grandfather was so resourceful
and that he made his own Veterinary
needles he would take a little piece of
wire and pound it flat with a with like
a oxyacetylene torch and then drilled a
little hole through it and then we would
do we did all of our own Veterinary work
some of the cattle even survived and um
uh so we had but we had great fun out
there you know
um we Built Barns and welded things and
he bought a D6 uh caterpillar bulldozer
used it was like 1955 model year for
five thousand dollars was completely
broken the gears were stripped and then
we spent you know a whole summer
repairing that the first thing we had to
do to repair it was build a crane to
take the gears out of the transmission
and so you know what I learned from
watching him was just how resourceful he
was he didn't ever call a repairman he
figured it out this work-life harmony
thing is what I try to teach young
employees actually in senior Executives
at Amazon too but especially the people
coming I get we're asked about work life
balance all the time and my view is
that's a debilitating phrase because it
um it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if I'm happy at home
I come into the office with tremendous
energy and if I'm happy at work I come
home with tremendous energy and so it
actually is a circle it's not a balance
and um and I think that that is uh is
worth everybody paying attention to you
want to have her you never want to be
that guy and we all know we all have a
co-worker who is that person who as soon
as they come into the meeting they drain
all the energy out of the room you can
just feel the energy level go that you
don't want to be that guy so you want to
come into the office and give everybody
a kick in their step one of the
precursors one of the foundational
things to being able to take risk is to
have had some kind of support from
somebody you have to have some mentors
you have to have somebody who loves you
these are the kind of things that build
up and allow you to kind of you know
jump off into Uncharted terrain and do
something new because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and uh and I certainly did so for me I
just want to point out that I I feel
very strongly that
um there's a lot I've won a lot of
lotteries Amazon is one of the lotteries
that I've won but I had a big lottery
with my parents my dad is a Cuban
immigrant he came here when he was 16
years old didn't speak any English uh my
this is a great guy and my mother
had her had me when and she was 17 years
old so she was a pregnant 16 year old in
Albuquerque New Mexico in high school
which was not cool and she made it work
and her her parents my grandparents
helped her with that whole thing and
made made that all work and if you don't
get that kind of support somehow it
doesn't have to be your parents
sometimes people get lucky it's a
grandparent or it's a friend or a family
friend or a teacher it can be somebody
but you need that somebody has to step
into your life and that's a lottery that
I suspect a lot of people in this room
have also won just like me you know you
don't choose your passions your passions
choose you and I would always advise
young people actually anyone you know to
get in touch with what you're really
passionate about and
to have a passion some people are lucky
they have more than one passion they
have two or three and that gives you
energy you can't force the passion on
yourself it just doesn't work you can
try but it's unlikely to succeed your
stock at one point I think went to a
hundred dollars but then it went down to
six or something like that at the peak
of the internet bubble our stock peaked
somewhere around 113 dollars and then
after the internet bubble uh you know
busted open our stock went down to six
it went from 113 to six in less than a
year my annual shareholder that year
starts with a one-word sentence and that
one word sentence is the word ouch
so most of those internet companies of
the.com era are out of business yeah you
survived what was that that made you to
survive and virtually the rest of them
are gone
um I it was very the whole period is
very interesting because the stock is
not the company and the company is not
the stock and so as I watched the stock
fall from 113 to six I was also watching
all of our internal business metrics
number of customers profit per unit
um uh you know everything you can
imagine defects Etc every single thing
about the business was getting better
and fast and so as the stock price was
going the wrong way everything inside
the company was going the right way and
um uh I you know so I wasn't we didn't
need to go back to the capital markets
we didn't need more money the only
reason you know a financial bus like the
internet bubble bursting is it makes it
really hard to raise money but you know
we already had the money we needed so we
just needed to continue to progress I
talk a lot about
willingness to be misunderstood that's a
really important thing to have if you're
going to do anything new or different in
the world it is going to be
misunderstood sometimes by well-meaning
critics sometimes by self-interested
critics you'll get all kinds and
it it's okay it's all part of the
process the only way to avoid criticism
altogether is to be completely
conventional in everything you do
and
so how do you respond to the criticism
what do you do what's the right thing to
do well I think the first thing you do
is you ask
are the critics right you listen you ask
are they right or even if they're not
completely right is there some piece of
it that's right that you can be inspired
by and then if you decide by the way
that the answer is no that you believe
you have conviction that what you're
doing is the right course
the No Force in the world should be able
to move you
you should have a deep Keel but if you
decide that your critics that there is
something then you should change and I
give you an example from the early days
of Amazon of one where we refuse to
change we were small enough that most
people didn't pay much attention to us
or care about us I'm taking you way back
to like 1995 1996
we pioneered this thing called customer
reviews
and I got a letter one day from a
publisher
a book publisher that said hey
um you must not understand your business
you're losing sales because you're
allowing negative customer reviews on
the book detail Pages why don't you just
put positive reviews
and I thought about this and I thought
no he's wrong we don't make money when
we saw things we make money when we help
people make purchase decisions it was a
different framing
and so getting to today's news
you know we listened to our critics and
we decided the framing that we have been
using all these years is competitive
compensation we look at what other job
opportunities there are and what the
competitive compensation levels are and
we offer competitive compensation and
actually
non-competitive World leading benefits
packages but just competitive
compensation
and
so in light of this you know thinking
about this and trying to decide do we
want to change we realized we just made
a decision well you can offer
competitive composition or you can
decide lead
and as soon as we framed it that way
we're like let's decide to lead it's a
great I think people will follow what
was it the critics said that caught your
eye basically they were saying they were
if you read between the lines because a
lot of the specific criticism was not
correct but if you read between the
lines what they really wanted us to do
they said because you could also say
look there's so many colors of all the
fast food companies there's you know the
Baristas and there's you know wait a
second why are you focusing on us but
that what they're really saying is we're
focusing on you because you're a leader
and we want you to lead that's what
they're actually saying and as soon as
you recognize it that way instead of it
feeling like criticism it feels
empowering they're asking us to lead
because we're a symbol of an Innovative
iconic company we're a gold standard for
Innovation we should lead never chase
the hot thing whatever it is that's
that's like trying to catch the wave and
you'll never catch it you need to
position yourself and wait for the wave
and the way you do that is you pick
something you're passionate about so
that that's the number one piece of
advice
that I give to somebody who wants to
start a company or or start a new
Endeavor inside of a bigger company make
sure it's something you're interested in
something you're passionate about
missionaries build better products
and so I would take a missionary over a
mercenary any day mercenaries want to
you know flip the company and get rich
missionaries want to build a great
product or service and you know one of
those great paradoxes It's usually the
missionaries who end up making more
money anyway there's one reason we have
done better than most of our peers in
the Internet space you know over the
last six years it is because we have
focused like a laser on customer
experience and that really does matter
uh I think in any business it certainly
matters online
where word of mouth is so very very
powerful you know if you make a customer
unhappy they won't tell five frames
they'll tell five thousand friends so we
are at a point now where we have all the
things we need to build an important and
Lasting company and if we don't it will
be shame on us you mentioned that you
wanted Innovation to inspire this next
Generation why is it important to you
why is it so important you personally to
make that happen well I think you know I
was a very lucky kid I was inspired by
invention and self-reliance from a
number of different people and from you
know even watching the Apollo program as
a little boy and I think when little
kids get inspired you'd never know what
might happen it's a big deal and
everything about our society gets better
over time I really do believe that I'm
an optimist you know the myth of the
good old days is usually just that a
myth we have better medicine than we've
ever had before uh everything you know
all of that is invention it's people
figuring out antibiotics it's figure
people figuring out new kinds of uh
biomedicines biotechnology uh it's
things that have been figured out with
the kind of communication that we have
the freedom of speech we have now with
the internet there's so many things that
are getting better and a lot of that is
powered by uh invention how do we get
young people re-engaged with government
service
well I think one thing and I I look at
this at Amazon too so I I don't think
it's just government service I think a
lot of these government organizations
are large organizations
and large organizations have a set of
problems and I worry about this at
Amazon I want us to have
this the scope and capabilities of a
large organization but the spirit and
heart of a small startup company
and and I and I think that so large
organizations one of the things
that happens is that the rate of the
decision-making velocity goes down and
it gets hard for large organizations to
make decisions quickly it's trivial for
a 50-person startup
they make decisions like this but a 500
000 person company like Amazon or a
giant government agency there's a lot of
levels of review and different things
and it can really slow and by the way
that young people don't want to work at
a company with a slow decision-making
process it's just not as fun as working
at a startup company or somewhere else
where so I think you can do that and
even in a large organization I think if
you if the leadership this is all about
leadership if the leadership focuses on
increasing the decision-making velocity
of the organization you will get
everybody will be happier it's more fun
um everybody will be happier at work and
you'll get younger people because that's
what they want you can also do every
single person who works in a large
company you get to decide you're going
to help increase the decision making
velocity are you going to bring energy
to the room we all know we all have
those people we work with them
as soon as they walk in the room
the whole room the energy level goes up
somehow they bring energy to that
conference room and we also all work
with people who are the opposite like
the second they walk in the room the
whole room
deflates
and you don't want to be that second guy
you want to be that first guy and you
and we all get to choose that we all get
to decide that so anyway I think you can
do it in big organizations and I think
one of the things that makes big
organizations less attractive to young
people is just
sometimes we're slow and you can fight
that and you can fix it if you look over
over long periods of time you know look
over hundreds of years and look at the
average sort of life cycle of a new
technology what you find is that it's
getting compressed and compressed and
compressed so the rate of change is
getting faster and faster every decade
that goes by they're sort of more
important discoveries per unit time than
there were in the previous decade
and and a lot of these discoveries tend
to uh you know have
two uses I mean Technologies and you
know tend to be agnostic with respect to
whether they could be used for good or
used for evil
and I think that you know over the next
50 years
we are gonna
face a lot of very tough decisions as a
society in in how we make sure that we
are harnessing those Technologies for
good purposes
I think Liberty giving people the
freedom to uh you know as long as
they're not hurting somebody else do
what they want is super important I
think it's the Core Essence of the
American dream and I think at times we
as people get confused about it I mean I
think one of the things that you see
come up uh in in various places and
people talk about it under different
labels sometimes they talk about it as a
lack of personal responsibility and
other kinds of labels but what it really
is is is I think people should you know
carefully reread the first part of the
Declaration of Independence because I
think sometimes we as a society start to
get confused and think that we have a
right to happiness but if you read the
Declaration of Independence it talks
about life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness nobody has a right to
happiness you should have a right to
pursue it and I think the core of that
is Liberty I think it's the very rare
idea that can be done by a single
individual almost everything that is
going to change the world solve a
problem improve something these are
usually big efforts and they require you
know teams a team working together to
really get something important done and
that has been the story of amazon.com
every step along the way we've had a
team here that is is making this work I
mean I don't know even even at the
smallest scale you have to figure out
how to get help from your friends from
your family members from people that you
can hire in those early days I think
without that it would never work you
need people who and this is very tricky
you need people who are experts in a
certain domain area because the world is
so complex today it's really hard to
invent something if you're if you're not
an expert if you don't have the
underlying tools at your disposal and
know what's going on you can't you know
invent something in neurosurgery without
knowing something neurosurgery
it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very Advanced and that's
true in every every field of endeavor
but to really be an inventor you have to
combine that expertise with The
Beginner's mind you have to have a
certain
childlike ability to not be trapped by
your expertise and that fresh look that
beginner's mind once you're an expert is
unbelievably hard to maintain but great
inventors are always looking they have a
certain Divine discontent and they they
may have seen something a thousand times
and still it occurs to them that that
thing even though they're accustomed to
it could be improved and that's you know
you have to look for people like that
and I also think cultures support that
you know you can't even if you're that
kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure you know willingness to
fail is critical for invention
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time you know most inventions
don't really work that well in the
beginning they're clumsy they're little
toddlers they're always falling and
tripping and so you have to have a a a
culture in your organization that
supports this kind of stumbling and
wandering uh you know you want just
because you're wandering doesn't mean
you're lost and that's a really
important thing to keep in mind when
you're trying to invent I very
frequently get the question
what's going to change in the next 10
years
and that is an interesting question it's
a very common one I almost never get the
question what's not going to change in
the next 10 years and I submit to you
that that second question is actually
the more important of the two because
you can build a business strategy
around the things that are stable in
time and so as you pointed out in our
retail business we know that customers
want low prices
and I know that's going to be true 10
years from now they want fast delivery
they want vast selection it's impossible
to imagine a future 10 years from now
where a customer comes up to me and says
Jeff I love Amazon I just wish the
prices were a little higher
I just wish you delivered a little more
slowly
impossible and so the effort that we put
into those things
spinning those things up
we know the energy we put into it today
will still be paying dividends for our
customers 10 years from now and so those
when you have something that you know is
true even over the long term you can
afford to put a lot of energy into it on
AWS
the Big Ideas are also pretty
straightforward it's impossible for me
to imagine that 10 years from now
somebody is going to say I love AWS I
just wish it were a little less reliable
or I love AWS I just wish you would
raise prices
it should be a little more expensive or
I love AWS and I wish you would innovate
and improve the apis at a slightly
slower rate
none of those things you can imagine and
so the Big Ideas in business are often
very obvious but it's very hard to
maintain a firm grasp of the obvious at
all times
but if you can do that and can and
continue to spin up those flywheels and
put energy into those things as we're
doing with AWS over time you build a
better and better service for your
customers on the things that genuinely
matter to them from the very beginning
in 1994 when I came across this fact
that the web was growing at 2300 a year
I was working on Wall Street very
specialized kind of Investment Bank
called a quantitative hedge fund a
company called de Shaw
and uh I uh when I decided I was going
to go do this crazy thing I went and
told my boss and he said well let's go
for a walk so we went on a two-hour walk
in Central Park
and uh he actually thought it was a good
idea it's a very smart guy his name is
David Shaw he's one of the few people I
know who has a fully developed left
brain a fully developed right brain just
a super smart guy and he said this is a
great uh idea but it would be a better
idea for somebody who didn't already
have a good job
um
and so
um and uh that was actually a compelling
argument to me and so I went away he
convinced me to think about it for two
more days and it was very hard to make
that decision and until I found the
right framework in which to make the
decision I think because I know there
are a lot of people who are interested
in entrepreneurial activities out there
I think this could be useful
it's it's the that it's the right
framework for me anyway to make the kind
of decision was a regret minimization
framework so I projected myself into the
future and I'm 80 years old and I'm
looking back on my life what do I want
to have done at that point I want to
minimized all the regrets that I have
and I knew that when I was 80 there was
no chance that I would regret having
walked away from my 1994 Wall Street
bonus or any of that kind of thing I
wouldn't even remember that but I did
think there was a chance that I might
regret not having participated somehow
and this thing that I thought was going
to be very exciting called the internet
and and I also knew that if I tried and
failed I wouldn't regret that so once I
thought about it that way it become
became incredibly easy to make that
decision there are a couple of other
things
that are essential for Innovation and
invention that are not as fun
one of them is you have to have a
willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be a
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way
I don't care what it is
people are initially going to
misunderstand it relative to the
traditional way and they will
they'll be well-meaning critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest
in the traditional they have some Profit
Stream tied to the traditional way
but but doing things and if you want to
if you never want to be criticized for
goodness sake don't do anything new so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time if you have a
willingness to fail then what you can do
is you can ramp up your rate of
experimentation so successful invention
successful invention is inventions that
customers care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation and that you can think
of as a process how do you go about
organizing your systems
your
people
um all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation because not all
of your experiments are going to work
just find something that you're
passionate about I would definitely on
the career advice side the most
important thing about your first job out
of school is to pick a place where you
think you're gonna you're where you're
learning per unit time is going to be
very high you can optimize for a bunch
of variables and it can get very
confusing you know where it's location
you know what's the salary going to be
and all those things are worth
considering they're all important but
make sure you pull back after you've
done your analysis and say am I also
picking the place that I believe my
learning per unit time is going to be
the fastest and you learn much more from
a best practices company than you do you
learn no matter where you go so if you
go work for somebody you're like God
these people are all crazy this is
insane you'll learn a lot of negative
lessons that you can use later and you
cannot do those things but that process
of elimination method takes a long time
so it's better to try and find a place
that has really high hiring standards
some of the basics especially you know a
place that's trying to recruit only the
you know the you know A's higher A's and
B's higher C's and C's higher D's so
you've got to hire only A's and you need
to pick a company that's doing those
kinds of fundamental practices as well
because then you'll learn so much it'll
set you up to do other things so I would
say that's probably the best career
advice I give I would definitely advise
a small Stirrup company to be as narrow
and as focused as is possible to be if
you look at the original Amazon business
plan
there was no hint of anything other than
books in it and it was not on my radar I
was thinking I wanted to build an online
bookstore that was it and you know
worked way better than I thought it
would and we launched music and that
worked better than I thought it would
and we launched videos I think it's so
long ago I can really remember I think
it was actually VHS tapes is that
possible and
um and that worked better than we
thought it would and then I sent email
to customers so I picked about a
thousand customers and I said
besides the things we sell today books
music and video what would you like to
see us sell and the list came back
incredibly long tail was almost like
whatever was on their mind at the moment
it was like I wish you sold windshield
wipers for my car and I was like really
windshield wipers that wasn't done the
business plan but that's an interesting
idea and so
um today we basically if you're buying
your windshield wipers anywhere else
you're probably getting ripped off um
and um so
um so it's been uh you know kind of one
foot in front of the other invention is
not disruptive only customer adoption is
disruptive at Amazon we've invented a
lot of things that customers did not
care about at all and believe me they
were not disruptive to anyone
so it's only when customers like the new
way that anything becomes disruptive and
so really it's just saying that you want
to you know if somebody comes to you
with a business plan that they claim is
disruptive you should ask them to
explain it to you in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
um why are they going to like it why is
it better than the traditional way it's
about definitely about leaning into the
future and so when you look at the kinds
of things that you want to be able to do
with your voice uh you know it it
changes for for those of you who have
used an echo the fact that it's always
on that you never have to charge it it's
always sitting there ready in your
kitchen or your bedroom or wherever you
put it the fact that you can talk to it
in in a natural way removes a lot of
barriers a lot of friction a lot of like
little tiny uh pieces of friction to be
able to do things to ask what the
weather is it's easier than taking your
phone out of your pocket and what what
has what people have found over and over
again is that by removing the tiniest
amounts of friction from ordinary
activities really people appreciate that
and and it improves customers lives one
of the key things about lean you know
defect reduction being efficient not
letting defects travel Downstream in any
process if you're going to eliminate
waste or as the Japanese call it muda
you have to have information
and
um
the data center has historically been an
information free zone as far as
application developers are concerned
you would write code
and you have no idea how it's consuming
resources you're too insulated because
you're in a pool of resources
and you can't meter it
one of the biggest still
unappreciated
benefits of AWS is that application
Developers
get a real sense of which inner loop is
driving all the cost
yeah and that's a big deal so that and
that's just starting to that's one of
the ways that that this approach to uh
infrastructure dramatically reduces
costs in our in our data center I mean
in our fulfillment centers and in our
customer service centers
we have
um uh we're always seeking to keep
defects from moving Downstream so this
is a you know a a principle that was
probably best applied in the early or
best first best applied by Toyota
and they had this idea of what they call
the andon cord which basically any
factory worker could pull the cord and
stop the whole automobile manufacturing
line
and for old school
auto manufacturing companies that was
considered crazy absolutely insane in
fact the opposite principle was
typically at work which is you did
everything possible to keep that line
running and here Toyota flipped out on
its head and they said look anytime
there's a defect no matter how small
they want you to pull the cord and stop
the whole line
and um
stopping things you know if you if you
do that in a line that has a lot of
defects initially you get a lot of and
on cord pulls and it's very expensive
and but over time if you use that
approach you eliminate the defects
closer and closer to the source and and
the people who are
fans of lean manufacturing and these
kinds of techniques
take almost as an Article of Faith
although there's a lot of evidence to
support this in very diverse industries
that the further a defect travels
Downstream the more expensive it becomes
to fix
and so you want to you want to stop
those things you don't want them to
repeat and happen over and over
sometimes you know we we expand into new
areas in two ways
um one is kind of you know from from a
customer need we will work from a
customer need to the skills that we need
and the other one is skills forward from
a skill set we have to a new set of
customers so Kendall is an example of a
customer need and you know so we don't
have any hardware skills we've been
doing this for 10 years now but we'll go
back and we'll go if you go back in 10
years we had no Hardware team we had to
hire somebody to lead our Hardware group
and then build a hardware team and build
some institutional competence at it and
so on
that um that's a customer need backwards
approach and then skills forward a great
example of that is Amazon web services
we had the skills to do AWS we had
probably more distributed computing
expertise than anybody else in the world
because of the transactions transaction
systems are so complicated and hard to
build and we had a service oriented
architecture of great complexity
probably before anybody else and so we
saw we could kind of because we were
doing that we could kind of see the
future a little bit and decide to build
AWS which has turned into you know a
huge business in its own right
and that is uh you know you if you were
always
business is very situational and so
rules of thumb are good but they have to
be applied to the right situation so
sometimes the old
the maxim that you should stick to the
knitting is correct but sometimes the
adage that you should stick to the
knitting is wrong and you know a senior
Leader's job is to figure out in which
situation are you because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
another amazing Jeff Bezos clip check it
out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there